foreign
man get your bandanas out it's time
for facts of your friends
oh man I'm looking at I set it up like
it's
so
today's facts here friends I'm just
gonna say at the outset this one's tough
because I'm Gonna Leave You with some
some concrete steps some concrete things
to look for
but I also I'm going to leave you with
some open-handed open-ended discussion
topics
um because
I'll be honest I struggle with this and
I should it's one of those things that
like as somebody who spent their years
working with abused and traumatized
people I should be able to Rattle this
off and I've called some of my
colleagues across the country I have sat
on the internets I've read books I
really struggle with the definition
of the word abuse
and when you say that's abuse we all
know what that is right it's it's
physical abuse it's harm it's somebody
hurting you it's psychological abuse
it's sexual abuse it's neglect right we
know
when we hear the word abuse it it's easy
to think like I can I know when I see it
right
like that old court case about
pornography like I know it when I see it
right
but as a science nerd it's just a nerd
in general that's not good enough I like
to Define it what is it and so I can
just a simple definition online I I this
is just a random place I just typed into
the Google's what is abuse and here's
the definition abuse is defined as any
action that intentionally harms or
injures another person that makes sense
right so some of my discussions with my
colleagues was
yeah it's an intent to harm it's an
action that that intends to hurt
somebody
the reason why I balk at that is neglect
is also abuse
like the last caller we had a dad just
sitting around while his kid needs to go
to the ER and he's just not paying
attention he's just eating chips he's
not trying to hurt that kid he couldn't
care less about that kid
that's abuse
and so there's no intent there
there's just neglect there's just
complete disregard and I would suggest
that still abuse and here's another
um challenge
um I had a colleague once that was we
were all having a meeting and the
meeting got got tense but we were all it
was a tense meaning we're also laughing
back and forth and the boss said
something right like the the highest
ranking person in the room said
something
and everybody's laughing
it was like a very passive quiet just
silly throwaway thing and it wasn't an
insult it wasn't a anything derogatory
it was just like ah
a little while later my colleague came
out of that meeting and she was rage
crying
rage crying
she was shaking to her core
and the way she explained it was this
incredibly abusive Behavior by the boss
I was there
everybody was there men and women
and nobody saw it
in fact we all saw the opposite we all
saw some attempts to kind of let the air
out of the room and to connect
and I think it would be dismissive to
suggest that her body was not in full
fight or flight her body had moved to
defend itself
to to run
to freeze to come back swinging
and so for me in my chair to be like ah
it's not abuse
I don't like that either
doesn't feel right and if we create a
culture where the end user the end
receiver is the person who defines abuse
you get the world we got now
where everybody's offended about
everything
and
you know when the cornerstones of
anxiety is you got to go through it you
got to work you gotta head right in the
middle of the storm that's where healing
is
but we've created a culture where
everybody's anxious about everything
everybody's fired up and worried about
everything and it's everybody else's job
in the world to bend their lives around
our offense or our discomfort
and it's chaos it's Madness it's a
moving Target so I don't like saying
that every person gets to Define abuse
for themselves that doesn't make sense
so I find myself in this quandary
I like the idea of abuse is harm right
it's a harm whether you meant it or not
I also think there's got to be some sort
of boundary there
otherwise you get into this these
thought crimes in this
you raised an eyebrow and all of a
sudden it hurt like it's just such a
mess
and so I leave that to you I think it's
an important topic to discuss how do we
Define abuse at the end of the day
um
I even have to go this far as I'm you
know I want you guys to see I guess
experience this annoying my wife tells
me I'm I try to think through an
argument in my mind and get all the way
to the end of the argument
um
I can also Imagine a scenario where
certain Behavior would be unifying in
one situation and abusive in another
right so it may be
um fun it may be unifying to poke to
make jokes with some of my childhood
friends
the very same jokes the very same
behavior may be unifying for us
and to somebody else like my wife or my
a colleague
that may trigger something that happened
when they were a kid and it's and it's
very re-traumatizing right
so I think approaching the world
I've got to
be able to speak my needs out loud
I gotta know when my body is reacting
and I have to be willing to be
hospitable and and humble
I gotta be able to say hey I didn't mean
harm it's probably best if we don't work
together I didn't mean harm anyway I
will never make say that again do that
again make that joke I had no idea I was
neglecting you I I thank you so much for
telling me
consider that problem fixed it's salt
right so I think it's a mix of both
um
here is
um this is from choosingtherapy.com
here's a couple of I'm just going to run
through a couple of some signs that you
may be in an abusive relationship
um
somebody's verbally abusing you they're
swearing at you they're yelling and
screaming at you
and sometimes you can abuse somebody
very very quietly
somebody threatens violence they
threaten to withhold love they were
threaten to withhold food or safety
right verbal abuse
um
unpredictable behaviors can be abusive
especially for kids when they don't know
what mom or dad they're gonna get
whether it's gonna be the rage dad or
the drunk dad or the angry mom or the
happy mom or the super
you know engaged at
their nervous system can never stabilize
it's always toggling with this hard back
and forth between the synthetic
comparison pathetic response it becomes
a mess
um cruelty to animals or others right
um
threatening behavior
forced sexual activity
or disregard for others desire
right you can be abusive through forcing
somebody to cater to your sexual whims
can also be abusive to withhold
connectivity
weaponize it
that can hold somebody hostage
um here's a couple other ones Financial
abuse
stealing money from the joint account
lying about expenses making making
somebody go through you or go through
them in order to spend money I've heard
of couples who somebody gives the other
person an allowance they got to run
every expense by year you don't have
your own debit card or whatever
or they have their own account right
there's Financial abuse
um there's taking out credit cards in
your name and spending money and racking
up debt that you've got to pay right so
um there's public shaming there's
harassment there's bruises and black
guys and by the way there's the fight or
flight or freeze response when we don't
talk about a lot it's a trauma response
an abuse response is fun
I'm gonna nuzzle up to you and get so
close to you
that you won't hit me anymore
I am going to get so close so it can
look like intimacy
it can look really really close so I
think the key here for me is
anything that makes my body feel like
it's got to protect itself could be
abusive Behavior it's not it's not a
guarantee every time anything that
causes my body's sympathetic nervous
system to fire up firefight ready to
rock and roll
could be it might not be it might be
that I'm really really tired I took that
the wrong way and that's where it's
incumbent on all of us to learn what we
need to learn how to regulate our own
nervous systems I can't Outsource that
to everybody I can't make that everybody
that everybody's job that's my job and
if you've experienced trauma that means
you've got some work to do you got some
healing to do that's hard
if you are being abused right now if
you're an abusive relationship
call somebody
call somebody call somebody
your life has value outside of being
somebody's punching back
you're worth being loved and you're
worth more than that call somebody
reach out to a local hotline if you
don't have a friend or like the last
caller
call some buddies and say it's I need
help come get me
and let's make a plan for what happens
next
Life's too short to be abused
and if you're abusing somebody
stop
go get help